ukraine's astonishing counter-offensive
has now reclaimed an estimated 8 000
square kilometers of territory from
fleeing russian forces in isiam russian
tanks and equipment were abandoned the
city largely destroyed but uplifted by a
surprise visit from president vladimir
zelinsky glory to ukraine he says
glory to heroes came the reply zielinski
saw the destruction left behind the part
of our real history
and the part of
of
modern today's russian nation
ukraine may be changing both the course
of the war and the world's view of it
in kazakhstan russia's neighbor where
regional leaders are meeting the kazakh
leader fretted in english over
geopolitical tensions
critical juncture in human history and
he welcomed the pope a staunch critic of
russia's invasion who called the war
senseless and tragic
but that meeting is a prelude to a
multi-nation summit this week in
uzbekistan at which china's xi jinping
will take center stage
vladimir putin said last week he will
meet xi at the summit
but chinese officials yesterday would
not confirm that as recently as last
month chinese troops were in russia for
joint exercises to demonstrate the
closeness of the two military powers
as to what exactly the chinese are
prepared to do
and more than likely vladimir putin is
pleading with xi jinping
for more help
help that few experts think she will be
willing to give not that tight and she
is too smart to fall for this he's not
going to give the russians weapons he he
knows which way the wind is blowing
melinda herring says to keep the wind
blowing in ukraine's favor the west must
supply more weapons and financing to
ensure that what ukraine has regained is
not lost
eric sorensen global news toronto